David Boder: [In English] This is reproduction Spool 9-45B—the beginning of the interview with Mr. Bramson, an executive of the ORT in Paris. The interview proceeds in Russian. November 14, 1950, Boder. Chicago.
David Boder: Paris, dieciséis...Paris, the 16th...[pause] Paris, the 16th of August, 1946, a interview taken from Mr. Bramson, the director of the ORT school at 12 Rue de Saules in Paris.
David Boder: [In Russian] Гн. Брамсон, дай...скажите нам, во-первых, Ваше полное имя и отчество, если...и возраст.
Jacques Bramson: Моё имя Жак, имя моего отца Александр.
David Boder: Да.
Jacques Bramson: Я родился в 1911 году.
David Boder: Так. И теперь скажите, Гн. Брамсон, Вы племянник или родственник того Гн. Брамсона, члена Государственной Думы в России?
Jacques Bramson: Да, я сын его брата, Александра.
David Boder: Как было полное имя этого члена Думы?
Jacques Bramson: Леонтий Моисеевич Брамсон.
David Boder: Из какого дистрикта был он членом Думы и в каком году?
Jacques Bramson: Города Ковно в первой Думе.
David Boder: Города Ковно в первой Думе. А потом какая была у него связь с ОРТом?
Jacques Bramson: Связь с ОРТом...можно сказать, что настоящей орг...поскольку организации в принципе существовали раньше, ОРТ, можно было сказать, был поставлен на ноги как международная организация Леонтием Моисеевичем Брамсоном. Потому что это он вывез эту идею из России и развил организацию на мировую...значит, ногу.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: Да, да, да.
David Boder: Теперь, Гн. Брамсон, я хочу, чтоб Вы совершенно, так сказать, свободно, нам рассказали Ваши личные переживания и вообще положение...эээ...на французской стороне Европы от начала войны до освобождения. Вы можете сесть теперь спокойно, и так просто говорить.
Jacques Bramson: Раньше, чем сказать...рассказать...мы лично переживали...я бы хотел Вам нарисовать картину положения во Франции после 1940 года, иными словами после Петенского перемирия. [Пауза] Несмотря на то, что Франция отдавала себе отчёт, что она была недостаточно подготовлена к войне, мы никогда не думали, что есть такая разница в силах между Германией и Францией. Начало войны в 1939 году нас ввело в контакт только с немецкими укреплениями вдоль Саарской области и...эээ...с немецким материалом. Этот материал нам казался не на очень высоком уровне и, действительно, может это было и так. Но немцы употребили во время этой войны совершенно новую тактику и такую массу этого материала, что французская армия была очень скоро разгромлена, и весь решительно народ, вся страна оказалась в таком положении полного морального смущения.
David Boder: Гн. Брамсон...Вы говорите «мы». Не хотите ли Вы нам сказать, как долго Вы жили во Франции, что Вы считаете, что Вы так сжились с французским народом?
Jacques Bramson: Я уже во Франции живу...эээ...20 лет.
David Boder: Здесь уже с 18...
Jacques Bramson: . . . 27 года.
David Boder: 27 года. И откуда Вы приехали во Францию?
Jacques Bramson: Я приехал во Францию из Польши. Но должен Вам сказать, что уже с самого детства я был воспитан немножко...ммм...на французскую манеру, у меня была французская гувернантка, и вообще в нашем окружении, как сказать? Госп...господствовала немножко французская культура.
David Boder: Это где, в Ковне?
Jacques Bramson: Нет, я в Ковне, можно сказать, никогда и не жил. Я жил в имении моего отца на Волыни, после мы жили в Киеве и в Крыму.
David Boder: Так, хорошо. Значит, теперь продолжайте со Франции. Значит, немецкая механическая и военная власть...сила...
Jacques Bramson: . . . разгромила окончательно французское сопротивление, и в этот момент...и когда страна стала...оказалась оккупированной немцами, то даже самые лучшие французские элементы находились в состоянии полного морального смятения! Этим объясняется факт, что в первый период, в первые полтора года можно сказать, что большинство французского народа ответило на призыв Петена. [Пауза] В первое время очень небольшая группа, состоявшая главным образом из бывших социалистических элементов и из тех элементов, которых с самого начала начали преследовать, которая начала работу, так сказать, подземного сопротивления в стране. [Пауза] В пропорциональном отношении...
David Boder: Подземное сопротивление—это то, что Вы называете «underground»?
Jacques Bramson: Да.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: . . . ммм...я принадлежал к этой сравнительно небольшой группе. Мы были несколько молодых военных...
David Boder: Ага. Вы были на военной службе во Франции?
Jacques Bramson: Да, я был...
David Boder: Скажите несколько слов об этом.
Jacques Bramson: Я был мобилизован как специалист...
David Boder: А Вы какой специалист?
Jacques Bramson: Я специалист...эээ...по-французски это называется «минар артифисье», иными словами сапёр, специалист по минам.
David Boder: А каких...какое образование Вы получили?
Jacques Bramson: Я...по образованию я математик-инженер Тулузского университета.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Кроме того, я прошёл военную школу сапёрную в Версале.
David Boder: Это до войны?
Jacques Bramson: Это до войны, когда я делал мою военную службу.
David Boder: А Вы были на военной службе во Франции?
Jacques Bramson: Я был на военной службе...я французский подданный!
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Я был на военной службе во Франции, и после я был мобилизован ещё за несколько недель до начала войны. Уже чувствовалось, что положение плохое. И на третий день войны я уже был на немецкой территории.
David Boder: Так. Вы были в офицерской форме?
Jacques Bramson: Да, я был...точно называется «аспирант».
David Boder: Ага. [Неразборчиво, очень тихо]
Jacques Bramson: Да. И...и, значит, я...об этом почти что никто не знал, потому что об этом я не рассказывал, не желая тревожить мою семью. На шестой день войны я уже был ранен, на проволочных заграждениях. Эээ...после моей раны я был из Саарской области отправлен на бельгийскую границу.
David Boder: Какой области?
Jacques Bramson: Из Саарской области, потому что я...
David Boder: Это Сааргебит?
Jacques Bramson: Да, Сааргебит. Я был ранен уже в немецкой территории, мы были...
David Boder: Саарской и вдруг показалось «царской».
Jacques Bramson: Да, нет—Саарская. Мы были на шестнадцать километров в глубине немецкой территории, когда именно мы попали на проволочные заграждения, во время атаки которых я был ранен.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: После этого меня перевели на бельгийскую границу, где я служил до входа французской армии в Бельгию 11 мая 1940 года.
Jacques Bramson: Я принадлежал в тот период к первой лёгкой блиндированной дивизии, которая вошла на бельгийскую территорию на встречу немецким войскам и которая была отрезана от остальных сил между Намиром и Филипвиллем в Бельгии.
David Boder: Блиндированная дивизия—это «armored division»?
Jacques Bramson: Да.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...некоторым отрядам этой дивизии, которая была окончательно уничтожена, удалось прорвать немецкое кольцо. Мне повезло, потому что я принадлежал к одному из этих отрядов, и мне удалось несколько недель после соединиться с французской армией под Компьен. Я принял участие в Соммской битве.
David Boder: В какой битве?
Jacques Bramson: Под Соммой...
David Boder: Под Соммой, да.
Jacques Bramson: . . . где я снова был легко ранен осколком в руку.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: А после Соммской битвы, которая решила, можно сказать, войну, потому что там был окончательно прорван последний французский фронт, я принимал участие в подступ...отступлении до Луары. Под Луарой...когда мы подошли—так как мы составляли арьергардную часть—все мосту уже были взорваны. Нам пришлось уничтожить наш материал, и всякими искусственными средствами перебраться через Луару. И после мы отступали до города Лиможа. [Пауза] Под Лиможем...эээ...немножко на западе от Лиможа, мы узнали о том, что Петен обратился с просьбой перемирия, и перемирие меня застало на этом месте. Эээ...немецкие войска подступали к этой области, и поэтому мы передвинулись на юг, не желая стать военнопленными.
Jacques Bramson: Я был...
David Boder: А скажите, во французской армии знали, что Вы еврей?
Jacques Bramson: Да.
David Boder: И как к Вам относились?
Jacques Bramson: Наш генерал был евреем. У нас...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: Что?
David Boder: Как его фамилия была?
Jacques Bramson: Его фамилия...эээ...[пауза] я не помню, она кончалась...это есть большое количество евреев, которые носят название лотаринских городов с окончанием на -анж. Это что-то было Оранж, Креанж—что-то в этом роде.
David Boder: А Вы не можете фамилию эту узнать как-нибудь для нас?
Jacques Bramson: Я постараюсь об этом узнать.
David Boder: Хорошо.
Jacques Bramson: Да. Но нас было довольно крупное количество. Я знаю, что в моём батальоне было около двадца...четыре еврея. Из них один капитан, два лейтенанта и, значит, я был аспирантом.
David Boder: Это Вы считаете крупное количество? Какой процент еврейского населения во Франции был вообще?
Jacques Bramson: Во Франции надо считать до войны было 120 французских...120 тысяч французских евреев и около...эээ...250 тысяч иностранных евреев.
David Boder: . . . евреев. А сколько...какое всё население Франции?
Jacques Bramson: Всё население Франции считался 41 мильён.
David Boder: Хорошо. Значит, продолжайте: Вы отступали, и Вас застало перемирие где?
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...немного на юго-западе от Лиможа.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Там я был демобилизован, и так как я раньше работал на одном заводе, который работал на авиацию, мне велели...эээ...разыскать этот завод, и отправиться на этот завод.
David Boder: Кто велели? Французы?
Jacques Bramson: Да. После демобилизации. С этой целью я отправился в Виши, где совершенно случайно я застал мою семью.
David Boder: А из кого состояла Ваша семья?
Jacques Bramson: Вот там находился Леон Тимофеевич Брамсон...
David Boder: Так. Дядя.
Jacques Bramson: . . . это по отцу мой дядя, его жена, его дочь. С ними я нашёл также родственников со стороны моей матери, которые там находились и которые там жили. Они во время войны...значит, во время...перед немецкой оккупацией бежали их Парижа и поселились в Виши, да.
David Boder: А правление ОРТа тоже было?
Jacques Bramson: Так, всё решительно правление ОРТа и ОЗЭ помещалось там в одном отеле, в одном и том же здании.
David Boder: ОРТ и ОЗЭ?
Jacques Bramson: И ОЗЭ.
David Boder: Они привезли с собой документы? Увезли...
Jacques Bramson: Всё было вывезено из Парижа. В Париже остались считано две школы, которые существовали. Это которые Вы видите теперь на Рю де Соль и другая механическая школа на Рю де [неразборчиво]. Но всё бюро...
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: . . . все бюро были перевезены в Виши.
David Boder: Ну, потом что?
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...В период демобилизации целая группа молодых военных решила организовать...эээ...[пауза] такое сотрудничество...
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: . . . потому что мы надеялись всё-таки, что в Северной Африке будет продолжаться сопротивление.
Jacques Bramson: Я принадлежал к этой группе молодых военных, и когда после Виши я попал в Марсель...эээ...со мной вошёл в контакт один из членов этой группы и просил меня организовать в Марселе ячейку для переправки военных в Северную Африку. Как раз в тот момент я работал там на одной фабрике, которая производила фруктовые такие всякие предметы из...эээ...восточных фруктов. Я там заведовал...
David Boder: Наверное, конфеты, соки?
Jacques Bramson: Соки и так далее. И вот я [пауза] там стал заведующим одного ателье. Мне это очень помогло, так как я мог собрать очень крупное количество французских молодых авиаторов, скрыв их как рабочих в этом заводе,...
David Boder: А Вы были в таком положении, что Вы могли нанимать рабочих?
Jacques Bramson: Да. Я нанимал, так как я заведовал ателье, так я нанимал рабочих.
David Boder: Ателье—это что, мастерская?
Jacques Bramson: Мастерская, да. И после этого я понемногу их переправлял, по мере возможности, на всяких маленьких корабликах и так далее, в...эээ...дальше в Северную Африку.
David Boder: Так. Французское Марокко?
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...нет, сначала главным образом они переправлялись в Тунис.
David Boder: В Тунис.
Jacques Bramson: Потому что в Марокко и в Алжире было...положение было гораздо более...эээ...тяжёлое в связи с тем, что там находились непосредственно...что находились непосредственно...эээ...контрольные немецкие комиссии, которые очень опасались английской выброски в этой области. Тунис находился скорее под итальянским контролем. Этот контроль был гораздо более неряшливый, и кроме того, тунисская администрация не была так скоро перекроена на мир Виши, как другие. [Пауза]...эээ...этот период...это сравнительно...это только начало борьбы. Количество этих людей, которых мы переправляли, было сравнительно небольшое, так как в армии. Ну, надо считать, что за весь этот период было переправлено около тысячи человек...
David Boder: О!
Jacques Bramson: . . . не больше.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Главным образом это были авиаторы и артиллеристы, и морские офицера. Это единственное...эээ...элементы, которых нас просили переправить и к...в армию де Голля. Так как эта армия в этот период не обладала ещё ни достаточным вооружением, ни достаточными снабжениями, и ещё ясно не видела своих возможностей. После переправка стала более массивной. Но морской путь оказался совершенно закрытым, и нам пришлось тогда прибегать к испанской границе. Этот период...эээ...был гораздо более тяжёлым. Виши успело реорганизовать свою полицию, и в один прекрасный день я имел неприятный сюрприз быть переведённым на полтора дня в марсельскую крепость. Мне повезло в том смысле, что я был арестован одновременно с сыном одного видного французского генерала, который моментально сделал нужные демарши, и так как его не могли выпустить одного, я был выпущен одновременно.
David Boder: Так. Он к вам тоже принадлежал в андерграунд?
Jacques Bramson: Он тоже принадлежал к этой организации.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...мне пришлось на пару месяцев...на пару недель прекратить работу. Это как раз совпало с очень тяжёлым периодом смерти Леонтия Моисеевича Брамсона.
David Boder: Так. Его похоронили где?
Jacques Bramson: Его похоронили в Марселе. Он похоронен в Марселе.
David Boder: И сколько ему лет?
Jacques Bramson: Ему было—точно я Вам не могу сказать—ему было около 70 лет.
David Boder: Не больше?!
Jacques Bramson: Нет.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Ему был 71год, если я не ошибаюсь.
Jacques Bramson: Нн...в [пауза] кроме того,...ммм...в этот момент мне предложили за...принять место...эээ...заведующего лабораторией в ОРТовской школе электромеханики в Марселе.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво] извиняюсь.
Jacques Bramson: Я принял это место, так как чувствовал, что в Марселе мне больше оставаться нельзя, так как полиция довольно зорко за мной следила. Я переправился тогда в Перигё, где я вошёл в контакт с [пауза] первыми организациями по сопротивлению. Я вошёл в контакт главным образом с самой крупной французской организацией «Комбат». Эээ...я просил, чтобы меня перевели в Африку, чтоб я мог отправиться после в экваториальную Африку, чтоб...или в Англию. Для меня уже было назначено место на одном пароходе с тем, чтобы спустить нас на маленьком корольке недалеко от Гибралтара. Я отправился в Марсель, занял место на пароходе...
David Boder: В качестве служащего?
Jacques Bramson: Нет, не в качестве...нас держали в отделении машин.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: В последний...
David Boder: . . . «stowaway» называется...
Jacques Bramson: Нелегально.
David Boder: Да [неразборчиво].
Jacques Bramson: К сожалению, в последний момент на пароход поднялась полиция—все врассыпную. Мои товарищи были переловлены. Я—так как я хороший пловец—бросился в море, и...ммм...мне удалось проплыть под водой небольшое расстояние, я спрятался за лодку. Меня выудил из воды один портовой служащий, который меня скрывал полтора дня, и после этого его...ему удалось меня провести под носом у полиции, вывезти с порта. Я вернулся обратно в Перигё, где сообщил о моей неудачной [говорит со смехом] поездке, о том, что товарищи были арестованы. Я...
David Boder: Где же Вы прятались на пароходе, что Вас не нашли?
Jacques Bramson: Я на пароходе...это...ммм...произошло так: паро...к пароходу...пароход уже был прицеплён к буксирам.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...и должен был уйти. В последний момент, видно, был какой-то донос, и в последний момент приехала полиция. Мы были...до этого полиция и сделала уже обход на пароходе, и нас спрятали в одном отделении около машин. Там был своего рода стальной шкаф, где нас...где можно было просидеть несколько часов.
David Boder: Сколько человек вас спрятали?
Jacques Bramson: Нас было четыре человека и одна женщина.
David Boder: Так, [говорит со смехом] мужчины?
Jacques Bramson: Четыре мужчины и одна женщина.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: И...вот...[пауза] один из наших товарищей, когда полицейские сошли—значит, первый осмотр—сошли [неразборчиво], поднялся наверх, чтоб закурить папиросу. И вдруг он начал кричать, что подъезжает автомобиль с полицией. Мои друзья потеряли голову и [пауза] вышли наверх. И когда первые полицейские вскочили, они подняли моментально руки вверх.
David Boder: Сдались.
Jacques Bramson: Сдались. Я спрятался за...эээ...пак...пакеты, которые лежали там...
David Boder: За багажом.
Jacques Bramson: . . . за багажом, И когда наверху остались только полицейские в мундирах, а тайная полиция сошла с нашего парохода, потому что...эээ...там кто-то сознался, что есть один ещё человек, которого они не задержали, я воспользовался, чтобы броситься в воду.
David Boder: Ага. И они видели, что Вы бросились в воду?
Jacques Bramson: По всей вероятности, никто не видел, кроме этого самого человека, который меня после прятал, который был на [неразборчиво]...
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: . . . служащий порта. Я проплыл под водой несколько метров и спрятался за лодку.
David Boder: Какое время дня это было?
Jacques Bramson: Это было приблизительно к часу дня.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Пароход должен был уйти утром, но он задержался из-за всех контролей, просмотров и так далее.
Jacques Bramson: Это было приблизительно в полвторого.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Он меня спрятал, этот служащий, в своей будке, как я Вам уже говорил, и вывел меня на следующее утро.
Jacques Bramson: Я вернулся, значит, как я Вам говорил, в Перигё, дал знать об этом невезении, и когда я второй раз подал прошение отправиться...эээ...в Северную Африку, мне сказали, что этот период отправок уже для нас менее интересен, что нам нужны люди на месте. Через пару недель я получил приказ [пауза] от товарищей, которых я считал моими шефами,...
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: . . . войти в контакт...эээ...с началом организации в этой области.
David Boder: Ага. Это в каком году было?
Jacques Bramson: Это было в самом начале 42-го года.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...организация эта...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво] в 41-ом?
Jacques Bramson: Что? Да. В начале 42-го года...эээ...произошёл один факт, который произвёл...который был довольно известен. Несколько парашютированных английских офицеров, которые занимались добыванием сведений во Франции, и французский депутат, который один из первых организовал здесь сопротивление, который, между прочим, был евреем—его фамилия Пьер Блок—. . .
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: . . . были арестованы и переведены в один из лагерей нашей области.
David Boder: Это значит, и английские офицеры, и Пьер Блок?
Jacques Bramson: И Пьер Блок. Тогда было...в этой области находился один концентрационный лагерь...
David Boder: Ага. Это лагерь назывался [неразборчиво, очень тихо].
Jacques Bramson: Лагерь...Нет, это под Перегё.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: . . . который назывался Мозак. И они находились в этом лагере.
David Boder: Это была неоккупированная Франция?
Jacques Bramson: . . . был на неоккупированной ещё области. И вот нам было поручена задача, чтобы...эээ...их освободить и дать возможность переправиться...эээ...в Африку. Это было, так сказать, первая...эээ...
David Boder: . . . конкретная...
Jacques Bramson: . . . конкретная вооружённая задача, порученная нашей организации. Нам это смогло очень удачно...удалось удачно это провести. В...английский аэроплан [пауза] находился на месте, где было условлено. Нам удалось это провести способом довольно оригинальным: мы переоделись в жандармов...
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: . . . и...поехали туда в лагерь, с фальшивыми бумагами, и нам этих людей выдали.
David Boder: Кого вам выдали?
Jacques Bramson: [Пауза] Если не ошибаюсь, семь англичан и Мр.Блок, ещё один—их девять человек.
David Boder: Вам их выдали. Вы переоделись во французские...
Jacques Bramson: Французскую форму.
David Boder: Полиции была форма?
Jacques Bramson: Нет, жандармов.
David Boder: А где же вы получили эту форму?
Jacques Bramson: Ну, это...очень много членов жандармерии работало в нашей организации, и даже несколько членов, кот...которые в этом лагере работали как офицера или как другие.
David Boder: Были на вашей стороне?
Jacques Bramson: Были на нашей стороне.
David Boder: Вы прошли туда с фальшивыми документами?
Jacques Bramson: [Неразборчиво] Единственное, что нам пришлось после разоружить одного из жандармов этого лагеря, которого нам...потому что...ммм...мы просили для более важного вида, чтобы нам были...дали ещё несколько человек эскорт.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: Так один из них оказался дураком и поднял шум, вообщем, мы ему заткнули пару платков в глотку и спустили его в одном месте в десяти километрах от центра деревни в лесу, и он после уж сам вернулся. А остальные—так они просили, чтобы их перевезли в Англию вместе, так сказать, с англичанами.
David Boder: Они их взяли?
Jacques Bramson: Их взяли. Они...после...они после вернулись, теперь они офицера в Индокитае.
David Boder: Скажите мне вот что:...
Jacques Bramson: Да?
David Boder: Значит, где же аэроплан был?
Jacques Bramson: Этот аэроплан находился...эээ...ещё заранее англичане обратились к нам с просьбой, чтоб им указывали места, где возможно спуститься на аэропланах.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Мы доставили по радио им сведения...эээ...ммм...очень многочисленных мест таких, и в одном из этих мест было условлено, что аэроплан спуститься.
David Boder: Что же, это был большой аэроплан?
Jacques Bramson: Это был сравнительно большой аэроплан.
David Boder: Сколько человек он взял?
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...значит, этот аэроплан взял девять человек.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Он был очень перегружён, когда он их взял, но [неразборчиво] это был двухмоторный аэроплан.
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...
David Boder: Сколько этот аэроплан стоял во Франции, прежде чем он их взял?
Jacques Bramson: Нет, он же спустился на пару...
David Boder: Часов?
Jacques Bramson: . . . часов, может на пару минут—я не могу сказать, потому что я...эээ...был только при начале этой акции.
David Boder: Вы не довели их до аэроплана?
Jacques Bramson: Нет, мы довели до аэроплана, но я уже при этом не присутствовал.
David Boder: При отъезде?
Jacques Bramson: Я при отъезде не присутствовал. Моя задача...
David Boder: Но Вы видели аэроплан?
Jacques Bramson: Я—нет, но мне товарищи рассказывали.
David Boder: Ага. Вы их довезли, а потом аэроплан взял...
Jacques Bramson: Да. Моя задача заключалась в том, чтоб после...мы имели маленькую организацию, которая должна была прикрывать передвижение автомобиля, который...эээ...перевозил этих людей. Автомобиль, который повёз...
David Boder: Повёз к аэроплану?
Jacques Bramson: . . . повёз к аэроплану.
David Boder: Так Вы с ними простились где? Около автомобиля?
Jacques Bramson: Да, я...эээ...как только они уехали из тюрьмы, больше я их не видал. И через два дня я услышал речь Пьера Блока, которую он произносил по английскому радио, BBC [смеётся].
David Boder: А тут можно было слушать BBC ясно?
Jacques Bramson: Нет, здесь, собственно говоря,...эээ...всеми силами как и немецкие власти, так и власти Виши старались эти посты заглушить. Но всегда находился один или два...эээ...ммм...две станции, которые были совсем неплохо слышны во Франции. Так что мы имели постоянные сведения, и можно сказать, что 90 % французского населения слушало...эээ...английское радио.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Наше движение начало разрастаться. [Пауза] К концу 42-го года мы организовали первые маки.
David Boder: Что значит слово «маки»?
Jacques Bramson: «Маки»—это [пауза] по-французски обозначает...эээ...заросшее, непроходимое пространство, джунгли.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Джунгли, понимаете?
David Boder: Это люди, которые работали в джунглях?
Jacques Bramson: Нет, это [неразборчиво] Первое название—это маки...это после это название расширилось. Слово «маки»—это то, что мы скрывали нашу молодёжь в непроходимых всяких местах: или в горах, или в лесах.
David Boder: Ага.
Jacques Bramson: . . . или в других местах.
David Boder: Это, так сказать, горные и лесные партизаны.
Jacques Bramson: Партизаны. Так что мы сначала...сначала мы не имели оружия, так что мы скрывали главным образом ту молодёжь, которую правительство Виши хотело отправить на работу в Германию, и скрывали военнопленных, которым удалось бежать из немецкого плена.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Скрывали мы также тех людей, которые преследуемы были. Евреи ещё в это время в маки шли неохотно. [Пауза]
Jacques Bramson: Потому что условия жизни в маки были очень и очень тяжёлые, и евреи приходили туда только в крайнем случае. А наш контингент главным образом состоял из бывших военных, из бывших военнопленных, а главным образом из молодёжи, которая не хотела ехать в Германию на работы.
David Boder: И что же, их просто прятали или их кормили?
Jacques Bramson: Сначала мы их прятали, и при помощи местного населения, которое мы распропагандировали, мы их кормили.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Ну, после [пауза] приходит 42-ой год, выгрузка в Англии и колоссальное расширение наших организаций.
David Boder: Выгрузка где? В Англии?
Jacques Bramson: Англичан и американцев в Африке.
David Boder: О, в Африке!
Jacques Bramson: . . . в Африке.
David Boder: Касабланка и северные...
Jacques Bramson: Да. Тогда...эээ...ещё до этого во французском народе произошёл колоссальный перелом. Увидели люди, что такое немцы. Эээ...этот период угнетённости, пассивности во французском народе, который был первые полтора года, прошёл. Люди начали оказывать пассивное сопротивление. Кроме того, увидели, что все речи Петена, что все эти отзывы, все эти...всё это было...были пропагандные истории. И всё решительно крестьянское население, за маленькими исключениями, которые, к сожалению, нам принесли очень много зла,...
David Boder: Эти исключения?
Jacques Bramson: Эти исключения. . . приходило к нам с посильной помощью. Должен Вам сказать, что если б не помощь этого населения, все бы наши организации вообще не существовали. Также не надо забывать, что приходилось...не надо забывать, что нам приходилось кормить сотни и сотни людей.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes...this concludes Spool 45 of the report of Mr. Bramson, and we shall continue on Spool 46. Paris, August, 194— [tape break] Paris, August, 1946, the 16th of August. We are changing spools for the continuation of Mr. Bramson’s report.
Herman Barnett: Spool 46, Spool 46. Recording starts in about one minute. Spool 46, this is Herman Barnett.
David Boder: This is Spool 46. This is Spool 46. Mr. Bramson continues. Paris, August the 16th, 1946, at the school of ORT, 12 rue de Saules...you say it in French?
David Boder: [In Russian] Жак Александрович, скажите Вы по-французски.
Jacques Bramson: [In French]...12 rue de Saules à Paris.
David Boder: 12 rue de Saules à Paris. [unintelligible]
David Boder: [In English] A recording of the Illinois Institute of Technology.
David Boder: [In Russian] Also...итак, Вы нам говорили, что мирное население [пауза], те, которые были на стороне немцев—их было немного—вам очень вредили, но остальное население помогло вам поддержать эти маки, которые главным образом были беглецы от рабочей повинности и...эээ...которые боялись французов. Евреев тогда ещё среди маки было мало. Продолжайте, пожалуйста.
Jacques Bramson: Я только что Вам сказал о том,...
David Boder: Что?
Jacques Bramson: Я только что Вам сказал о том, что среди французского населения произошёл большой сдвиг. Очень важным элементом этого сдвига были массовые депортации евреев с июля 1942 года. Этот факт произвёл на французское население очень тяжёлое впечатление. Были демонстрации студентов в Париже, было недовольство...
David Boder: Против депортации?
Jacques Bramson: Против депортации. Были...в Париже очень много студентов было арестовано за эти демонстрации и были отправлены в лагеря вместе с евреями. Эээ...значит, в маленьком городке Перигё, где я жил, толпы народа собрались на улице и буквально плакали, когда видели, что происходило.
David Boder: Расскажите нам подробно о манере ареста евреев и их депортации.
Jacques Bramson: О манере ареста евреев—были две манеры. Одна манера была в оккупационной области...в оккупированной области немцами. В этой области полицейские власти находились полностью под немецким контролем и принуждены были полностью выполнять [неразборчиво]. Индивидуально, полиция очень часто предупреждала людей, или когда кого-нибудь не находила, очень не настаивала. Что же касается неоккупированной зоны, то всё это происходило исключительно в зависимости от начальника местной полиции. Были такие области—например, в нашем округе, где боль...где большинство пол...[пауза]. Были такие области, где, как наша, где большинство полицейских находились в нашей организации. Там они па...шесть тысяч человек, которым угрожал арест, и на восемьсот человек, которых они получили ясный приказ арестовать, было арестовано всего сто пятьдесят. И они этим удовольствовались. Но были другие города, где начальники полиции были [пауза] или антисемитские элементы, или пропетеновские элементы—там аресты были поголовные. Кто не мог спрятаться, был арестован.
David Boder: Ну, скажите мне, тут щекотливый вопрос.
Jacques Bramson: Да?
David Boder: Нужно было, скажем, арестовать восемьсот или тысяча людей.
Jacques Bramson: Да.
David Boder: Арестовывают только сто пятьдесят, потому что симпатичные.
David Boder: Кто были эти сто пятьдесят? Кто были эти, так сказать, козлы отпущения?
Jacques Bramson: Эти козлы отпущения были люди, которые своевременно не спрятались. Потому что происходило это так: могу Вам точно рассказать, потому что я этим сам занимался. [Пауза] За пять дней до этой большой облавы мы получили сообщение о том, что подготовляется какая-то облава. Против кого, точно не было известно. Говорилось о том, что сосредоточены автобусы, что сосредоточены полицейские силы и так далее. Одновременно была...прошёл слух о том, один служащий префектуры нам сообщил, что [пауза] лиможская полиция потребовала у него список всех иностранных евреев, живущих в области Перигё.
David Boder: Какая полиция? Скажите по-французски.
Jacques Bramson: Из города Лимож.
David Boder: А скажите по-французски это.
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...[говорит по-французски].
David Boder: Как было дальше?
Jacques Bramson: Тогда мы поняли, что дело касается евреев. Мы уже знали, что подобные облавы произошли в оккупированной области, и поэтому мы дали знать, по мере возможности, всем решительно евреям, чтобы они дер...держались начеку, и чтобы они не ночевали у себя на квартирах.
David Boder: Где ж они могли ночевать?!
Jacques Bramson: Они ночевали у соседей...
David Boder: У...
Jacques Bramson: . . . христиан, у евреев-французов, которых не трогали, потому что эти меры касались сначала только иностранцев-евреев. Они...некоторые уходили в сады и там они проводили ночь.
David Boder: Это было какое время года?
Jacques Bramson: Это было в июле месяце 42-го года.
David Boder: Да.
Jacques Bramson: К концу июля месяца. Были элементы, которые пренебрежительно отнеслись к нашим предупреждениям. И эти элементы—так как нужно было пару сот козлов отпущения—главным образом эти элементы и потерпели.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Могу сказать, что большинство арестованных—это были дети, женщины, и [пауза] взрослые люди. Потому что сначала у людей было впечатление, что будут они искать только мужчин. Мужчины спрятались, оставляли своих...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво] взрослые, женщины и дети.
Jacques Bramson: Мужчины прятались, оставляли дома детей и жён. И они забрали жён и детей.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Отношение к арестованным...эээ...тоже зависело от местного начальника полиции. В большей части отношение сначала было очень корректное. Но были также области, где полиция себя некрасиво вела.
David Boder: А когда этих людей убирали, что...что делалось с их вещами?
Jacques Bramson: Можно сказать, что...что в этом смысле...в оккупированной области на их квартиры клались печати, и занимался этим специальный ликвидационный комитет по еврейским делам немецкий.
David Boder: Так. Немецкий. Там были еврейские служащие?
Jacques Bramson: Нет, там не было еврейских служащих. Там этим занималася французская полиция и гестапо.
David Boder: Так. И что они делают? Они...
Jacques Bramson: Они большей частью вывозили все ценные вещи и позволяли грабить остальное. Ценные вещи они сами ликвидировали—продавали, а остальное отдавали...
David Boder: . . . на ограбление?
Jacques Bramson: Да, на грабёж. Неофициально.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Что же касается неоккупированных зон, так полиция относилась так очень широко, давала возможность родственникам забирать все вещи или...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: Ну, здесь это вообще была такая жизнь. Вот была облава.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Три дня люди прятались, на четвёртый кончились облавы, они приходили, снова на шесть месяцев спокойная жизнь. Тут же снова начинались облавы и так далее. Так что были какие-то периоды затишья, и понимаете, [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Так. Вы не забудьте в самом конце объяснить нам эту карту ОРТа, с посещением школы.
Jacques Bramson: Я с удовольствием Вам объясню.
David Boder: Хорошо. Ну, вот...
Jacques Bramson: Вобщем, как я рассказал, это произвело на народ очень сильное впечатление.
David Boder: На французов?
Jacques Bramson: На французов. И тогда правительство пошло немножечко на попятную. И в течение некоторого времени официальные сообщения были о том, что это касается исключительно иностранцев, что это нежелательные элементы и так далее. Так что...эээ...но люди стали относиться ко всему этому с большим недоверием. После этих облав в этих самых наших маки появились уже более многочисленные еврейские элементы. Молодёжь еврейская тоже начала появляться. Тогда, как я Вам уже сказал, маки уже представляли из себя довольно организованную сумму на момент выброски американско-английской в Африке.
David Boder: Так. А Вы находились с ними в контакте?
Jacques Bramson: Да.
David Boder: Ну, теперь опишите нам жизнь маки. День жизни маки.
Jacques Bramson: Я Вам это опишу, потому что я командовал целой областью. Ну, во-первых...в своём лагере, должен Вам сказать, что...
David Boder: Что Вы имеете ввиду под лагерем? Лагерь был...?
Jacques Bramson: Лагерь [пауза] лагерь, который я Вам опишу, потому что я лучше всего его знаю, так как я там провёл девять месяцев, и так как там находился наш генеральный штаб, находился в 40км от города Перигё. Находился он в глубине леса, на одной горе, с которой хорошо контролировались дороги. Попасть в этот лагерь—то, что мы называли лагерем—человеку несведущему было совершенно невозможно. Я сам раза четыре или пять раз потерял дорогу.
David Boder: . . . когда шёл туда.
Jacques Bramson: В этом лагере нас было двести человек. Жили мы...двести человек, из них было человек тридцать, которые работали в нашем штабе, имели там радиосообщение, имели телефон внутренний, имели в этом лагере подземные склады для амуниции...
David Boder: А откуда вы доставали амуницию?
Jacques Bramson: Вот. Амуницию мы доставали двумя способами: когда немцы после прихода в неоккупированную область распустили французскую армию, эта армия не сдала своего оружия, его припрятала. Она припрятала сток, так как много было.
David Boder: Припрятала что?
Jacques Bramson: Сток. Эээ...то, что в складах находилось.
David Boder: Ага...
David Boder: [In English]...the ammunition dumps.
Jacques Bramson: Запасы. Да, запасы. После большое количество офицеров и солдат армии перешло к нам. Пропорционально, они составляли ничтожную часть, потому что это были люди дисциплированные, им велели ничем не заниматься, они ничем не занимались. Были элементы всё-таки, которые на нашу сторону перешли. Эти элементы указали нам, где мы можем раздобыть оружие. Кроме того, мы...эээ...раздобывали оружие, но некоторые вещи не могли раздобыть. Например, лёгкое вооружение, как...эээ...например, маленькие авто...автоматы называемые.
David Boder: Что, автоматическое оружие?
Jacques Bramson: Да, маленькие.
David Boder: Да...
David Boder: [In English]...automatic rifles.
Jacques Bramson: [In Russian] Да.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: И так далее. То этих вещи мы не могли раздобыть. Напротив, у нас было довольно большое количество более тяжёлого вооружения: тяжёлые пулемёты, «гаубицы», и так далее.
David Boder: Как? Голубицы?
Jacques Bramson: Гаубицы.
David Boder: Мортиры?
Jacques Bramson: Мортиры, да, мортиры. И вот...эээ...тогда в области Альп уже англичане парашютировали довольно большое количество оружия. И вот тогда мы обменивали наше тяжёлое оружие на более лёгкое, которое перевозили...
David Boder: С кем обменивали?
Jacques Bramson: С другими маки. Да. И перевозили...и перевозили...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво] Без обмена не дали бы?!
Jacques Bramson: Им же нужно было какое-нибудь оружие тоже. Значит, кроме того, большое количество оружия приходило с немецких складов, которые у нас атаковались и грабились, набеги делались.
David Boder: Вы их...?
Jacques Bramson: Большое от убитых немцев, которых мы [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Так. Ну, теперь вернёмся: жили как вы, в палатках?
Jacques Bramson: Нет, у нас даже не было палаток. Мы были недостаточно богаты. Главным образом мы строили дома из ветвей.
David Boder: Строили дома...?
Jacques Bramson: . . . из ветвей. Да,...
David Boder: Шалаши.
Jacques Bramson: Шалаши своего рода. Нам повезло, что с нами было много дровосеков—потому что все решительно дровосеки были с нами—и они нас научили, как строить эти сооружения.
David Boder: Среди маки были люди не военноспособные, как, например, евреи?
Jacques Bramson: Да,...а у нас евреи все были боеспособные. Не боеспособных мы не могли брать. Жизнь была такая тяжёлая, человек нездоровый мог выдержать в большем одну неделю, десять дней.
David Boder: А каким...как вы получали свои продукты?
Jacques Bramson: Наши продукты нам пос...эээ...приходило на помощь местное население. Происходило это таким образом: у нас по всем деревням были подпольные [пауза] были подпольные организации. Эти подпольные организации собирали у крестьян продукты или покупали продукты, и привозили нам в условленные пункты. Ночью маленькие наши отряды отправлялись туда или с автомобилями, или прямо на спине и переносили все эти продукты в лагеря.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Но...у нас была организована наша бойня, так как крестьяне нам поставляли скот. У нас были организованы кухни, и вообще была настоящая военная организация. Дни...день проходил очень просто: будили в шесть часов, давали полчаса на мытьё и на завтрак, в семь часов был раппорт.
David Boder: А где вода? Была вода?
Jacques Bramson: Да, мы выбирали места недалеко от ручьёв.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...в семь часов был раппорт. И аппель. Собирались все решительно перед флагом, поднимался флаг.
David Boder: А Петен переменил флаг?
Jacques Bramson: Петен оставил те же самые цветы.
David Boder: Цвета.
Jacques Bramson: Цвета. Французский флаг остался. Только [неразборчиво], где было сказано [говорит по-французски] Republique Francaise, т.е. Французская Республика, были заменены словами [говорит по-французски] Etat Francaise, т.е. французское государство. Кроме того, раньше все французские учреждения имели на своих печатях Марианн. Это символическая женщина Франции. Эээ...Петен заменил эту символическую женщину фашистским...эээ...
David Boder: Свастикой?
Jacques Bramson: . . . знаком. Это была не свастика, это были два топора, перекрещённые. Значит, этот топор перерубал голову гидре.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Так вот,...эээ...перед флагом одновременно им давались сообщения, которые за ночь получали по радио. Сразу после этого часть...половина занималась всякими работами в лагере: устройство и так далее, а вторая половина ходила на маневры.
David Boder: Так. Вы носили формы?
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...форму мы импровизировали. Нам удалось...эээ...в разных лагерях была разная форма. Эээ...нам удалось атаковать один лагерь французский, где мы нашли очень много...эээ...мундиров, так что наши отряды все были обмундированы, даже очень хорошо обмундированы. В других областях часто бедным нашим молодым людям...совсем они босиком были—совершенно ничего не было. Нам повезло, потому что нам удалось, во-первых, нам удалось...раз мы атаковали несколько немецких грузовиков, которые перевозили из одной обувной фабрики большое количество сапог и обуви, так что мы могли целую дивизию одеть. А кроме сапог нам удалось также...эээ...в одном лагере—для этого нам пришлось сделать рейд 250км—нам удалось перевезти три грузовика больших мундиров.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Так что к концу, я могу сказать, за несколько месяцев до моего ареста, когда начались более серьёзные военные действия, наш этот лагерь и все решительно маки нашей области были более или менее хорошо одеты. К сожалению, они были наполовину вооружены.
David Boder: Так. Вернёмся теперь к [неразборчиво] облав...эээ...
Jacques Bramson: Да.
David Boder: . . . это были первые облавы на евреев, евреи стали более...
Jacques Bramson: . . . осторожными.
David Boder: . . . осторожные и более внимательными к маки. Ну, тогда отсюда продолжайте.
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...должен Вам сказать, что после этих первых облав, евреи, которые до сих пор относительно пассивно переносили все свои несчастья, у них тоже переменилось [неразборчиво]. У евреев появилось желание, более сильное, чем раньше, потому что они видели всё-таки, что сопротивление организуется в мире. Чувствовалось, что Америка войдёт в войну, после они увидели, что она вошла в войну. И вот у них появилось активное желание сопротивления. До того, как я должен был окончательно покинуть город, потому что раскрыли мою деятельность, я преподавал в ОРТовской школе и заведовал ОРТовской школой в Перигё.
David Boder: Как далеко Перигё от Виши?
Jacques Bramson: От Виши километров 250.
David Boder: И от Парижа?
Jacques Bramson: И от Парижа километров 400. Перигё находится между городом Лиможем и городом Бордо. Эээ...так вот, среди молодёжи...молодёжи от четырнадцати до двадцати четырёх лет [пауза], у них появилось такое желание активно самим что-то делать. И мне удалось там организовать [неразборчиво] целую молодую группу, которая со мной была до самого конца. Должен Вам сказать, что...
David Boder: «Конца» Вы считаете до Вашего ареста?
Jacques Bramson: Нет, до моего освобождения.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: И должен сказать, что это был единственно нормальный выход из положения. Среди этой группы, которая боролась, которая рисковала своей жизнью, было гораздо меньше потерь, чем среди евреев, которые прятались и сидели, сложа руки, ожидая, что их арестуют. Пропорционально было гораздо меньше потерь. Должен Вам сказать, что ОРТовская школа в Перигё—она...эээ...себя проявила также в области сопротивления. Потому что мы были окончательно лишены всей решительно радиоаппаратуры. И у нас в первое время не было возможности организовать никакой связи.
David Boder: Связь для маки?
Jacques Bramson: Да, маки.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: И вот первые аппараты для маки и приёмники [неразборчиво] были построены у нас в школе.
David Boder: [In English]...for transmission and for reception...
Jacques Bramson: . . . reception.
David Boder: . . . were built in the ORT school.
Jacques Bramson: [In Russian] И вот тот мальчик, который налаживал и строил эти аппараты, был после арестован и послан затем в Германию. Шестнадцатилетний мальчик, его фамилия Кан. Это был молодой...
David Boder: Какой? Как его фамилия?
Jacques Bramson: Я первое имя не...Жан-Пьер, если не ошибаюсь. Жан-Пьер Кан.
David Boder: Жан-Пьер...
Jacques Bramson: Это был молодой эльзасский еврей.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: И он, значит, он при помощи нашего инструктора строил эти аппараты. Кроме того, у нас в школе было содружество...
David Boder: А кто был инструктор?
Jacques Bramson: Инструктор—это был француз, Марсель Гудо.
David Boder: Он знал об этом?
Jacques Bramson: Да, да, да. Я его ввёл в это [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Очень много из наших учеников к концу получили медали.
Jacques Bramson: Один из этих молодых людей находится у меня тут в школе. Он имеет две недели...две медали!
David Boder: После освобождения?
Jacques Bramson: Уже после освобождения. Он был взят в плен [неразборчиво] и вернулся. У нас было починено очень много оружия, в школе в наших мастерских: [неразборчиво] пулемёты, ружья, револьверы. Были заделаны части для...эээ...мортир, и так далее. Всё это делалось ночью, всё это, конечно, доверялось только тем молодым людям, которым мы могли полностью доверить. Их было немного, пять—шесть человек. Эти пять-шесть человек делали замечательную работу. Эээ...
David Boder: А французское правительство это признало?
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...французское правительство это признало, потому что все эти молодые люди после моего возвращения—я подал об этом заявление—все они были награждены орденами и медалями.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Погибло...так что сопротивление начало организоваться серьёзно к концу 42-го года. Тогда период начальной организации уже был...превозошёл. И тогда началась открытая борьба. Эта открытая борьба велась многими способами. Во-первых, террористическая работа. Было признано, что немцев нельзя оставить в покое, что они должны чувствовать себя во Франции как на вулкане. И поэтому всё время [пауза] то атаковали автомобили, то подкладывали мины под поезда, то взрывали организации гестапо или штабы и так далее.
David Boder: А скажите, [неразборчиво] для мирного наделения [неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: Очень плохие результаты.
David Boder: Для мирного населения?
Jacques Bramson: Для мирного населения. Должен Вам сказать, что к концу количество это было такое, что немцы уже не могли реагировать. Сначала они брали заложников. Они расстреливали заложников.
David Boder: Маки это знали?
Jacques Bramson: Маки это знали. После они, видя, что это происходит—обратный результат...
David Boder: . . . обратный...
Jacques Bramson: . . . обратный результат, они прямо так заложников не брали, А говорили, что арестовывают евреев или коммунистов и так далее. [Неразборчиво] брали первых людей, которые находились [неразборчиво]. Когда расстрелы...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво] публично?
Jacques Bramson: Публично нет, но во всяком случае вывешивали огромные [неразборчиво, очень тихо]...организовали большие лагеря и начали отправлять всех заложников в центр Компьен, откуда их переправляли в Аушвиц, Бухенвальд, Монхаузен и все эти великие лагеря в Германии, где они тоже погибали, Потому что всего 20 % сосланных вернулось. А для евреев этот процент был гораздо меньшим, потому что их 110 тысяч евреев, высланных из Франции в Германию, вернулось около 6 тысяч человек.
David Boder: Около 6 тысяч.
Jacques Bramson: 6 тысяч человек.
David Boder: [In English] Of a hundred and ten thousand deported Jews from France there returned approximately six thousand.
David Boder: [In Russian] Так.
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...ну, мы долго-долго задумывались над этим вопросом, но мы считали, что останавливаться нельзя. Мы только тогда прибегали к таким мерам: мы никогда не старались вызвать крупное количество жертв среди немцев, чтобы не вызывать среди них ещё большого озлобления. Мы не старались атаковать второстепенные всякие организации, которые чисто полицейского характера не носили. Мы...брали...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво].
Jacques Bramson: [Неразборчиво].
David Boder: Так вы нападали на организации, которые носили полицейский характер.
Jacques Bramson: . . . полицейский характер или индустриальный характер. Вторая работа террористическая—это был так называемый саботаж. Все фабрики, которые немцам позволяли ещё работать во Франции...
David Boder: Немцы позволяли?
Jacques Bramson: Ну, да, немцы. Они работали, собственно говоря, на Германию. [Пауза] В особенности металлургическая французская промышленность [неразборчиво] как и автомобильная французская промышленность. И вот, мы начали саботировать. Самым известным актом саботажа—это был взрыв трансформатора самого большого металлургического завода во Франции «Крезот». С тех пор завод «Крезот» больше никогда не начал работать.
David Boder: И до сих пор не работает?
Jacques Bramson: Нет. Теперь его возобновили после...эээ...в 44-ом году он был снова пущен в ход.
David Boder: Когда немцы ушли?
Jacques Bramson: Когда немцы ушли. Но между 42-ым и 44-ым годом завод без перебоев работал ровно неделю. После второго саботажа снова остановился. После второго саботажа немцы решили его больше не использовать.
David Boder: Скажите, а что сделалось с рабочими, которые были выброшены за борт во время этого саботажа? Сколько рабочих имел завод?
Jacques Bramson: Завод «Крезот» в тот период имел не такое большое количество рабочих. Их было около 10 тысяч.
David Boder: Десять?!
Jacques Bramson: Нормально было гораздо больше.
David Boder: Хорошо.
Jacques Bramson: Но эти рабочие...их же тут же на месте употребляли для того, чтобы восстанавливать снова завод. Или их переводили в другое место, а часть рабочих [неразборчиво] немцы отправляли в Германию.
David Boder: Так там были [неразборчиво, очень тихо].
Jacques Bramson: Да, значит, мы старались, насколько возможно рабочих, которых отправляли в Германию, по дороге освободить. Должен Вам рассказать коми...комический случай, как один парень, находящийся в голове [неразборчиво], в котором было 800 человек, потом пришёл в город Лимож—этот тот, что находился в 80 км от города Перигё—там оставалось ровно 60 человек.
David Boder: Как же им удалось бежать?
Jacques Bramson: Вдоль железнодорожной линии были расположены маленькие отрядики партизан, отдали приказ рабочим давить на тормоза. Поезд останавливался пять или шесть раз, и они оттуда выскакивали. Когда французы...французская полиция пробовала интервенировать, то моментально...эээ...появлялся отряд партизан, и полиция французская против партизан, можно сказать, никогда не реагировала.
David Boder: А скажите, а кем сопровождался поезд? [Неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: Поезд...поезд сопровождался по большей части французской полицией, которая тоже смотрела сквозь пальцы, позволяла людям убегать. Понятно, не массивно. А если человек двадцать убегало, то они на это не обращали внимания. Но понятно, такие массовые побеги могли только при помощи партизан.
David Boder: Так. Ну, вот, вернемся к [неразборчиво].
Jacques Bramson: Следующий элемент нашего сопротивления—это была пропаганда. Пропаганда...модно сказать, что все газеты, которые теперь выписываются и продаются в Париже—это были бывшие подземные газеты.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Эти...ммм...эта...эти газеты—их них самая крупная была газета «Комбат».
David Boder: Так. А она не существовала перед войной?
Jacques Bramson: Перед войной она не существовала. Эта газета вышла в 41-ом году. Его главным издателем и организатором был Рене.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Среди сотрудников этой газеты было немало евреев. [Пауза] Эээ...были другие очень крупные газеты, как «Фронтера».
David Boder: А какую партию «Комбат» газета представляла?
Jacques Bramson: «Комбат» во время сопротивления—это была партия социалистической молодёжи.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Но после она превратилась в беспартийную газету сопротивления, и так и осталась беспартийной газетой сопротивления. Было что характерно для «Комбат» в настоящий момент, что это газета, которая...ругает [смеётся, неразборчиво].
David Boder: [Неразборчиво].
Jacques Bramson: Это...это признак деголлевской армии. Это так называемый Лотаринский крест.
David Boder: Ага.
Jacques Bramson: Лотаринский крест—это крест области, которая больше всего страдала всегда от немцев, был принят символом всего французского сопротивления. Все солдаты армии сопротивления освобождения французского носили эти Лотаринские кресты. [Пауза] Эээ...одной из очень важных наших деятельностей—это было подорвать влияние правительства Виши, влияние Петена. И в этой области мы вели беспощадную работу. Кроме того, мы вели борьбу со всеми фашистскими французскими организациями. Фашистские французские организации были много раз нами окончательно истребляемы во многих городах, и им прошлось их искусственно восстанавливать. Мы не останавливались...эээ...перед тем, чтобы убивать людей на улицах и так далее, чтобы прямо их терроризировать.
David Boder: Фашистов?
Jacques Bramson: Фашистов. В конце концов, французским этим организациям пришлось [пауза] реорганизироваться в военную организацию, в милицию.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: И с этой минуты мы повели настоящую военную борьбу. Были настоящие битвы, между партизанами и этой французской милицией. Французская милиция на всей французской территории имела около сорока тысяч человек. Из неё около восемнадцати тысяч переехало вместе с Петеном в Германию.
Jacques Bramson: После освобождения Франции.
David Boder: И где они теперь?
Jacques Bramson: Теперь они большей частью...маленькая часть...маленькой части удалось бежать...
David Boder: . . . бежать куда?
Jacques Bramson: В...эээ...они рас...эээ...в Германии спрятались между лагерями, сменили национальность, и так далее. Остальные были выданы, их небольшая часть расстреляна, остальные ждут суда.
David Boder: И кто их расстреливал?
Jacques Bramson: Первое время они...эээ...это военные суды, главным образом военные суды французской освободительной армии партизан. А после, когда военное время...военные период был объявлен оконченным во Франции они предстали перед простой французской...перед нормальными французскими судами и обвиняются в измене по отношении к Родине.
David Boder: Так. [Пауза] Теперь, как были другие случаи...я хочу на историю Вашего ареста начать новый спул. [Неразборчиво] специальные истории из жизни во Франции или [неразборчиво].
Jacques Bramson: Вот я Вам могу...эээ...рассказать несколько ха...характерных таких сценок [пауза] нашей жизни. Эээ...это было в середине июля 43-го года. Нам сообщили о том, что после того, как мы сделали довольно неудачную попытку, чтобы взять в плен начальника французской внутренней полиции Бернана,...эээ...немецкие власти и Виши устроили против нас большое передвижение военных сил. Мне сообщили о том, что в десяти километрах от нашего лагеря сосредоточены несколько эскадронов так называемых. Жерме—это была военная полиция, соответствующая эсэсам. Эээ...
David Boder: Шутцштафель?
Jacques Bramson: Шутцштафель. Вообщем, я решил, так как положение было серьёзное,...эээ...поехать сам на разведку. Я отправился на легковом автомобиле с несколькими людьми. В одном месте мы заметили первых мотоциклистов этих жерме. Эээ...Я заметил среди них одного офицера. Тогда я вышел и пригласил офицера, чтоб он [неразборчиво] для переговоров. Вообразите себе моё удивление, когда этот офицер подошёл ко мне, вытянулся в струнку, и представился офицером жерме такой-то и такой-то, но член секретной армии. И вообщем, мне удалось с ним заключить следующее соглашение.
David Boder: [In English] We have to interrupt at a very interesting point...we have to interrupt at a very interesting point [unintelligible].
David Boder: Spool 48. Paris, August the 16th. Continuation of Mr. Bramson’s report.
David Boder: [In Russian] Но Вы говорите, что Вы в конце уже не были в Бухенвальде. Каким образом это случилось?
Jacques Bramson: Дело в том, что раньше, чем сдать лагерь Бухенвальд американцам,...эээ...немцы выбрали...эээ...пятнадцать тысяч человек, которых они решили отправить как заложников в лагерь в Дахау, т.е. в области, где ещё близко не находились американские войска. Это была часть Германии, где они ещё надеялись сопротивляться. И я принадлежал к этой группе.
David Boder: Почему они называли их заложниками?
Jacques Bramson: Они их...потому что в этот момент...эээ...мнение Геббельса было таково, что надо обязательно иметь людей, которые бы отвечали за жизнь, потому что рассказывали всякие истории о том, что американцы и...ммм...русские убивают моментально эсэсов, которые они берут и так далее.
David Boder: А это было...разве не было правдой в известных случаях?
Jacques Bramson: В известных случаях, может, это было правдой, но поскольку я видел американцев, французов и англичан эсэсов не убивали [неразборчиво]. К ним строже относились, чем к другим пленным, но они считались как военнопленные.
David Boder: А маки?
Jacques Bramson: А вот партизаны, и кроме того, население, очень часто их уничтожало. Партизаны относились к ним совершенно беспощадно.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: По дороге нас гнали пешком. Мы сделали около трёхсот километров пешком.
David Boder: Сколько дней?
Jacques Bramson: Шли мы около двух недель.
David Boder: О! Так.
Jacques Bramson: Кормили нас...мы получали по стакану зерна в день. Это было нежжёное зерно.
David Boder: Что это—нежжёное зерно? Не молоченое?
Jacques Bramson: Не молоченое зерно.
David Boder: Что это было: рожь? Ячмень?
Jacques Bramson: Главным образом, это была пшеница.
David Boder: Пшеница. Ели зерно?
Jacques Bramson: Ели зерно, у большинство людей появилась дизентерия. Начиная с третьего дня люди падали по дороге. Эсэсы их тут же приканчивали. За каждой колонной ходила группа истребителей, которые убивали всех отстающих.
David Boder: Как они их убивали?
Jacques Bramson: Они прямо выстрелом или из револьвера, или из ружья.
David Boder: Так. Мужчины и женщины тоже были?
Jacques Bramson: У нас только мужчины,...
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: . . . женщин с нами не было.
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...я сам должен был отнести в канаву на дороге моего товарища Жусса, очень известного авиатора, который первый вместе с Хермозом перелетел Южную Атлантику.
David Boder: Какой авиатор?
Jacques Bramson: Хермоз.
David Boder: Французский авиатор?
Jacques Bramson: Да, да. Это был Жусс, это был помощник Хермоза.
David Boder: Какое его имя?
Jacques Bramson: Жус? Его имя пишется Ж...о...у...два с.
David Boder: Это его имя?
Jacques Bramson: Да. Жусс.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: Да, он очень знаменитый человек. Это он с Хермозом перелетел в первый раз Южную...
David Boder: Атлантику.
Jacques Bramson: Атлантику.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Так я должен был сам отвести в канаву, где при моих глазах тут же его прикончил...эээ...потому что больше ходить не мог. Я ему...
David Boder: Его сперва переводили в канаву, а потом...
Jacques Bramson: Я должен был его перенести туда, потому что иначе его бы растоптала толпа, которая...он упал уже на месте. Чтоб его толпа не растоптала, я должен был его отнести.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: И наша группа была сначала пять тысяч человек.
Jacques Bramson: После...
David Boder: Вы сказали пятнадцать или...?
Jacques Bramson: Пять. В нашей...в моей группе было пять тысяч.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: После [пауза] количество с каждым днём уменшивалось. В конце нас осталось, после недели,...эээ...нас остались две колоны по тысяче человек.
David Boder: Так. А сколько...?
Jacques Bramson: Все остальные были убиты по дороге.
David Boder: По дороге. Что их, хоронили или что?
Jacques Bramson: Нет, оставляли лежать. Они ещё лежали...я после этого ехал на автомобиле пятнадцать дней позже, ещё почти что все трупы лежали разлагалися.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Так. В этом...после...к концу мы...ммм...нас...приблизительно 20-го апреля нас оставалась небольшая группа, около тысяча человек, которая шла в пяти колоннах. Надо сказать, что эсэс, которые нас аккомпанировали, находились не в лучшем положении, чем мы. Они были ужасно расслаблены,...эээ...[пауза]. Их положение усложнялось ещё тем, что мы все наши вещи бросили, а им приходилось ещё таскать всё оружие и мешки.
David Boder: А что они ели?
Jacques Bramson: Ели они лучше нас, но ели тоже очень плохо. Воровали в деревнях немножко картошки и так далее.
David Boder: Эсэс?
Jacques Bramson: Да. [Неразборчиво] у нас фактически не было. [Пауза] Американская армия передвигалась за нами с той же быстротой, что и мы. Мы всё время находились приблизительно в пятнадцати—двадцати километрах от фронта.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: И каждые полчаса мы надеялись, что мы будем освобождены, и каждый раз эти надежды не...
David Boder: . . . не выполнялись...
Jacques Bramson: . . . не выполнялись. Один раз, когда мы были на горе, то внизу видели атаку американских танками одной антитанковой немецкой батареи.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...но [пауза] американцы остановились после этого на два дня, и мы снова передвинулись на тридцать километров на юг.
David Boder: Ну, а вы показывали какие-нибудь знаки радости или удовольствия?
Jacques Bramson: Да, [неразборчиво] не произвело. Наши конвоиры были уже так измучены и усталы, что они автоматически выполняли приказы офицеров, которые разъезжали на машине и на велосипедах.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Ммм...никакой реакции. Они автоматически убивали людей, если велели кормить, они бы их кормили...
David Boder: Так. Это были эсэс?
Jacques Bramson: Это были эсэс.
David Boder: Ну, да.
Jacques Bramson: Мы видели, что наша группа всё таяла и таяла. В один прекрасный день мы услышали пулемётный огонь. По этому огню мы решили, что борьба происходит недалеко, в пятнадцати—двенадцати километрах.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: И поэтому мы решили рисковать.
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...мы собрались...эээ...целая группа людей, которые...которая между собой была знакома, и решили отстать. И понемногу начали отставать, сформировали небольшую колону, которая стала [неразборчиво] всего десяток расслабленных эсэсовцев.
David Boder: Ага.
Jacques Bramson: Пулемётный огонь всё время приближался.
David Boder: Это были все французы или...?
Jacques Bramson: Было там несколько поляков, русских и французов.
David Boder: А евреи были там?
Jacques Bramson: Среди нас евреев не было.
David Boder: . . . среди вас евреев не было.
Jacques Bramson: Евреи были в другой группе, которая находилась в километре перед нами.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Они были освобождены на день поз...на день после нас.
David Boder: Так. И вот?
Jacques Bramson: Мы тогда бросились на эсэссов. Несколько человек пробовало защищаться, другие бросили оружие и удрали.
David Boder: Так. А те, которые пробовали защищаться?
Jacques Bramson: . . . защищаться, тех мы прикончили.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Мы взяли их оружие и удрали в лес.
David Boder: Так. [Неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: Нас было...ммм...между шестидесятью и восьмидесятью.
David Boder: Так. И вы удрали в лес.
Jacques Bramson: Через...эээ...часа четыре первые американские части прошли через этот лес. Тогда мы вышли из леса.
David Boder: А американцы вас узнали?
Jacques Bramson: Да, мы же были в полосатых одеждах лагерных.
David Boder: Так. Ну?
Jacques Bramson: Ну,...эээ...американцы в тот же день догнали эти две колоны, которые были перед нами—одна состояла главным образом из евреев, а другая была смешанная—и их тоже освободили.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: [Пауза] Мы...по совету американских офицеров мы отправились на север, где нам обещали помощь. Помощь нам, фактически, не оказали. Но американцы нам позволил реквизировать всё, что нам было нужно, и мы организовались [неразборчиво] французов в маленьком городке Фрейзинг, который находится недалеко от города Ханн.
David Boder: Немецкий город?
Jacques Bramson: Да, немецкий. Баварский город Фрейзинг.
David Boder: Как пишется?
Jacques Bramson: Ф –р- е-й-н-а-с
David Boder: . . . з—и...
Jacques Bramson: . . . н—г...
David Boder: Фрейзинг.
Jacques Bramson: Фрейзинг.
David Boder: Что вы организовали в этом городе?
Jacques Bramson: После этого, в согласии с американским командованием, мы перевели на себя руководство всей области.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Так что мы там организовали госпиталь для раненых, для больных. Мы там организовали снабжение, мы там организовали полицию, которая занималась нашими делами так и делами городская сеть и окрестности. И мы занимались тем, что пробовали войти в контакт—об эвакуации ещё не было речи, фронт был ещё длинным—мы пробовали войти в контакт с французскими отрядами, которые находились тоже недалеко от события.
David Boder: Так. А как немцы к этому отнеслись?
Jacques Bramson: Немцы совершенно потеряли голову. Они в течение трёх дней ходили всё время или с белыми повязками на рукавах, или с белыми флажками на шляпах.
David Boder: Так. Не было попытки их арестовать?
Jacques Bramson: Все...все решительно эсэс, которых мы встречали, они были моментально убиты. Поймали мы также нескольких наших бывших...эээ...людей, которые занимали посты форарбайтеров, капо и так далее в лагерях, тоже очень многие были убиты. Арестовывали...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво] капо почему?
Jacques Bramson: Это...они больше всего нас преследовали в лагерях, Не смотря на то, что были такие же заключённые, как мы.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: Среди французов было очень мало их, потому как французы...
David Boder: А кто они были?
Jacques Bramson: Кроме того...главным образом, это были немцы...
David Boder: Так. [Неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: . . . и поляки. Немцы и поляки, главным образом. Было маленькое количество чехов, но чехи, французы, бельгийцы...эээ...вели себя очень прилично большей частью.
David Boder: Были и евреи?
Jacques Bramson: Самое ужасное...евреев в Бухенвальде не было. Евреев было много в других лагерях. Но в Бухенвальде еврейских капо не было.
David Boder: Что это за название «капо»?
Jacques Bramson: Это от латинского слова «caput»—голова.
David Boder: Ага, так.
Jacques Bramson: Так вот эти самые...и многих мы узнали, и которые не спрятались, были повешены. Кроме того, арестовывали мы—все немцы старались пере...переодеваться в штатскую одежду, чтобы не попасть в плен.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: Мы арестовывали всю решительно молодёжь и доставляли их в американские лагеря.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...
David Boder: А питались вы чем?
Jacques Bramson: Питались мы тем, что реквизировали у немецкого населения.
David Boder: Так. А как население к этому относилось?
Jacques Bramson: Население вело себя [пауза] очень спокойно, и все...низко себя вело. Я никогда не ожидал от немцев такой ни...унижения такого.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Да. В этом...мы вошли в контакт с французскими отрядами.
Jacques Bramson: И когда у нас положение стало налаживаться,...эээ...одна французская колона снабжения, после того как прибыла и привела милицию [неразборчиво], заехала в наш городок и нас забрала.
David Boder: Т.е., взяла с собой?
Jacques Bramson: Да, всех французов, бельгийцев и голландцев с собой забрала, и всех решительно людей, которые происходили...которые были арестованы во Франции. Среди них было также немало евреев.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Я с ними доехал до города Бромберга.
David Boder: Так. Немецкий город?
Jacques Bramson: Немецкий город.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: В городе Бромберге...там...эээ...мои товарищи были отправлены в центр, который занимался тем, что репатриировал людей во Францию, а...ммм...несколько человек из нас—так как мы не хотели ждать—решили собственными средствами добраться.
Jacques Bramson: Я пошёл вот представиться к французскому коменданту, который был офицером связи с американцами. Он меня...нас представил американскому генералу—я не помню его фамилию—и тот попросил врача военных транспортов, чтобы он нас забрал. На военных транспортах мы доехали до города Майнца. За городом Майнцом уже стояли французские гарнизоны. Так что французские офицера нас на своих автомобилях довезли до первого приёмного пункта для беженцев из Германии. Там нас одели, дезинфекцировали и привезли в Париж.
David Boder: Так. Ну, что Вы нашли в Париже?
Jacques Bramson: В Париже, понятно, мы были очень разочарованы. [Пауза] Потому что, понимаете, когда мы вели эту борьбу, боролись и так далее—может, это было не совсем логично—но мы сами себя убеждали,...
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: . . . что мы делаем что-то такое [со смехом]...
David Boder: . . . очень важное.
Jacques Bramson: . . . будущее, идеальное и так далее. Ну, а нашли мы Париж в очень плохом экономическом состоянии, царил настоящий голод. Встретили нас, правда, замечательно, но повсюду люди страдали.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: Население на улицах и всюду..., нам всюду приносили подарки.
David Boder: Как они узнавали вас?
Jacques Bramson: Нас легко было узнать, мы были все такие худые. Я потерял свыше 20 кило, например. У нас у всех были срезанные волосы, и мы ходили ещё в полосатых костюмах.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Так что нас приняли замечательно, с большим энтузиазмом отправили...к сожалению, очень много наших товарищей умерло после приезда уже во Францию.
David Boder: Эээ...отчего они умерли?
Jacques Bramson: Главным образом истощение.
David Boder: Нельзя было их подкормить? Нельзя было...
Jacques Bramson: Очень...большинство было спасено, но очень многие были ещё ослаблены тем, что в первый момент ещё освобождения они набросились на пищу, что вызвало всякие осложнения, как дизентерия и так далее.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: У меня пять или шесть моих товарищей скончались в госпитале в Париже.
Jacques Bramson: Несмотря на все старания самых лучших профессоров и так далее.
David Boder: А...
Jacques Bramson: Значит, наше разочарование вызвано было тем, что, к сожалению, по прежнему царил ещё этот кошмар во Франции—чёрный рынок,...
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: . . . что бедным элементам было очень тяжело, между тем как всякие нувориши позволяли себе невероятные вещи.
David Boder: А кто были эти нувориши?
Jacques Bramson: Это были люди, которые разбогатели...эээ...или сотрудничая с немцами, или занимаясь чёрным рынком, или...эээ...всякими манипуляциями с американцами и так далее.
David Boder: Так. Ну?
Jacques Bramson: Кроме того, что на нас произвело нехорошее впечатление, что сразу после освобождения Франции...началась эта подземная политическая борьба. Снова. Открыто не велась, открыто это был общий фронт, но внутри были постоянные интриги и происходили многие совершенно некрасивые вещи...эээ...для этого периода. [Пауза] Кроме того,...эээ...во Франции произошёл тот факт, который, к сожалению, логично должен был произойти. Самые лучшие элементы сопротивления [пауза] состояли во главе военных групп. Во главе этих военных групп они находились на фронте. А всё решительно административное дело в руки взяли второстепенные элементы,...что вызвало это ослабление влияния сил сопротивления, ослабление моральной силы которого представляли эти группировки, а главным образом, тем, что большинство из этих людей пришли в движение в последний момент и не видели во всём этом ничего другого, как возможность сделать блестящую карьеру.
David Boder: Кто это были, которые пришли?
Jacques Bramson: Все они...например, высшие элементы были как простые офицера на фронте...
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: . . . потому что они стояли во главе своих отрядов, во главе...ммм...всех своих организаций, были включены в армию. Однако надо было перестроить всю организацию, надо было организовать снабжение и так далее. И к этому пришли люди, которые до сих пор фактически ничего не делали, потому что другие все находились на фронте. Так что, вообщем, перестройка морали во Франции была поручена в тот момент вовсе не тем, которым полагалось взять её в руки, а элементам...эээ...совершенно неопределённым. Это было фактом, что и очистка среди администрации и так далее шла сравнительно медленно и не смогла быть проведена в нужном [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Так. А скажите, почему силы резистанские не настаивали на том, чтобы...
Jacques Bramson: Силы...дело в том, что все силы резистанс находились на фронте: или на Атлантическом фронте, или в Германии. Первая армия французская состояла главным образом из сил резистанса. Эта армия была...
David Boder: Первая армия, которая сформировалась после...?
Jacques Bramson: Да, она состояла из наших...Нет, она была сформирована уже раньше, потому что юг Франции был освобождён ещё до освобождения Парижа.
David Boder: Каким образом?
Jacques Bramson: В результате...эээ...партизанских сил. Область, в которой я находился—там ни одного никогда ни англичанина, ни американца, ни одного деголлевца не было. Все города [неразборчиво]...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво] после...
Jacques Bramson: Нет.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво].
Jacques Bramson: Нет, [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Ага.
Jacques Bramson: В этой области были [неразборчиво] партизанские отряды, например, города Бордо...
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: . . . Лимож, Ля Рошель, Тулуза—все это города—там никогда не было ни деголлевцев, ни американцев, ни англичан. Эта часть Франции была освобождена исключительно партизанами.
David Boder: А каково было отношение партизан к де Голлю?
Jacques Bramson: Все решительно партизаны были...находились под командованием де Голля, и все они были деголлевцами.
David Boder: Так. [Пауза] А чем объясняется то, что [неразборчиво] так сказать.
Jacques Bramson: Я не сказал бы, что де Голль в тени. Де Голль ушёл сам. Это вызвано тем, что де Голль не политик, да Голль только военный. И его некоторые взгляды не соответствуют идее французской демократической. И поэтому он сам ушёл.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...дело в том, что...эээ...де Голль сделал, несмотря на большое уважение и любовь, которые к нему имеют, сделал много грубых политических ошибок из-за своего чисто военного темперамента. И для блага внутреннего положения Франции, и частично для наружного, он совершенно правильно поступил, что ушёл со своего поста.
David Boder: Так. Ну, теперь скажите, что Вы потом начали делать, когда вернулись в Париж?
Jacques Bramson: Когда я вернулся в Париж, моё здоровье было очень расшатано. Мне предписали уехать. Эээ...здесь была очень трогательная сторона: организация сопротивления устроили для нас...для нескольких моих товарищей и меня специальный дом отдыха, который был построен на том месте, где когда-то находился мой штаб в лесу, про который я говорил.
David Boder: Там построили новый дом или что?
Jacques Bramson: Там рядом находился маленький дворец, который они реквизировали для нас. Мы там жили, проводили там время. Этот дворец находился несколько километров от того места, [неразборчиво]
David Boder: А Вы были там сколько?
Jacques Bramson: Я пробыл там шесть недель.
David Boder: Шесть недель...[неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: [Неразборчиво] это французские организации...нас представляли, у нас всё время были визиты, люди приезжали на автобусах. Хорошо было.
David Boder: А потом Вас связали с ОРТом опять?
Jacques Bramson: Эээ...когда я вернулся,...эээ...так мне ОРТ сделал предложение снова сотрудничать. Я в первый момент ещё колебался, потому что мне предложили [неразборчиво] пост в военном министерстве.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Но я не был во всём согласен...с политическими течениями, которые тогда существовали в военных кругах, и поэтому я от этого поста отказался и принял управление ОРТовскими школами в Париже.
David Boder: Скажите мне вот что, Гн. Брамсон, как в ретроспективе...Какие были...эээ...какие-нибудь особые моменты...Вы так никогда до Дахау не дошли?
Jacques Bramson: До Дахау я не дошёл.
David Boder: Так. Хорошо. Скажите, есть какие-нибудь особые моменты,...так сказать, которые Вы считаете важными, так сказать, и интересными?
Jacques Bramson: В каком смысле? В личном смысле или...?
David Boder: Давайте возьмём оба. Есть вопросы, которые я не мог задать другим, [неразборчиво, большие помехи]
Jacques Bramson: Да.
David Boder: Что [неразборчиво], что происходило в половом и сексуальном отношение, скажем, в Бухенвальде.
Jacques Bramson: В этом отношении людей надо было разделить сначала на две категории, а после эти категории ещё на другие.
David Boder: Так, продолжайте.
Jacques Bramson: Эти две большие категории...была одна, которая находилась в таком физическом и моральном состоянии усталости и измождении, что для неё половой вопрос практически не существовал. Я знаю, что для меня после месяца пребывания в лагере этот вопрос практически перестал существовать. Это было такое состояние физического голода, что этот вопрос не существовал. В лагере были другие элементы, которые работали не тяжело, которые сравнительно могли—потому что они крали—сравнительно хорошо питаться.
David Boder: А у кого они крали?
Jacques Bramson: Они крали у своих товарищей. Это были, прежде всего, капо, форарбайтеры...
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Они крали пакеты, они крали на кухне...
Jacques Bramson: И вся эта администрация лагерная, и несколько там людей, которые подлизывались к ним, так вот у этих элементов этот вопрос существовал, да.
David Boder: Как они её решали?
Jacques Bramson: Решали её [неразборчиво]. Должен Вам сказать—многие люди не верят—дело в том, то немцы [пауза] вот с 1943 года устроили в лагерях публичные дома.
David Boder: Да.
Jacques Bramson: [неразборчиво] были элементы, которые регулярно посещали эти публичные дома.
David Boder: Что? Они платили за это?
Jacques Bramson: За это платили.
David Boder: Откуда они брали деньги?
Jacques Bramson: Деньги они не брали, но дело в том, что за нашу работу в лагерях нам теоретически платили лагерными бонами. Проституткам платили лагерными бонами.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: [Неразборчиво] эти деньги.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: [Неразборчиво] и под полицейским присмотром тоже.
David Boder: Так. И что, надо было просить разрешение?
Jacques Bramson: Надо было обратиться к лагерному, значит,...эээ...[неразборчиво] к блоку получить разрешение. Нам он давал письмо, тогда мы шли к врачу на осмотр, врач находил, что мы можем идти туда. Оттуда выходили, мы получали впрыскивание и дело к концу.
David Boder: Ну, а другая категория?
Jacques Bramson: Другая категория—это люди, которые очень давно находились в лагерях. Главным образом, это были немцы и поляки.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: И...среди которых необычайно было распространено [неразборчиво] всякие рукоблудия и тому подобные вещи.
David Boder: Так. И?
Jacques Bramson: Это у них было очень много. Такого количества [неразборчиво] я никогда не воображал.
David Boder: Ага.
Jacques Bramson: Должен сказать, что среди...эээ...немецких заключенных старых политических много [неразборчиво] было 20 %.
David Boder: Это полититческие?
Jacques Bramson: . . . которые уже сидели много-много лет. [Неразборчиво]
David Boder: И они удовлетворяли свои...
Jacques Bramson: Это происходило, конечно, довольно комичном образом. Вы же знаете, что в лагерях были не только политические заключённые. Мы были смешаны вместе с уголовными преступниками, с ворами, а также [неразборчиво] по цвету треугольников, которые мы носили на груди.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: И вот там была специальная категория—сексуальные преступники.
Jacques Bramson: Эти сексуальные преступники...входила категория [неразборчиво]...тоже доставляли в лагеря. И вот сначала они были в своём блоке.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Отдельный блок, и они там вели такую роскошную жизнь, что эсэсовцы [неразборчиво]. Они начали считать, что попали не в лагерь, а попали в рай [смеётся].
Jacques Bramson: И вот вообщем их после разогнали по всем решительно блокам [говорит со смехом].
David Boder: И сказалось их влияние?
Jacques Bramson: [Неразборчиво] влияние—это чересчур, во всяком случае, они [неразборчиво] драки, неприятности и так далее.
David Boder: А скажите мне, Вы встречались, например, с кем-нибудь, с теми молодыми людьми, которых я теперь интервьюирую в Бусикау? Они где были, в отдельных блоках?
Jacques Bramson: Видите, это были не старые бухенвальдцы. Это была молодёжь, которая была раньше в Аушвице и других лагерях.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Их перевели в Бухенвальд только после того, как русские заняли эту область.
Jacques Bramson: Так что эта молодёжь...она находилась...эээ...она была разбросана. Часть находилась в Большом лагере—были отдельные два блока для молодёжи.
David Boder: Ага.
Jacques Bramson: А часть находилась в Маленьком лагере. К этому моменту я имел контакты гораздо меньше, так как тогда, когда их привезли, я работал уже не в лагере в Бухенвальде, а каждое утро уходил на работу в Ваймер и вернулся только вечером.
David Boder: Ваймер?
Jacques Bramson: Ваймер, да, да.
David Boder: А разве Ваймер не был бомбардирован тогда?
Jacques Bramson: Ваймер был бомбардирован три раза, но это ещё один из немецких городов, который не очень пострадал.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Гораздо больше пострадал сам лагерь в Бухенвальде. Потому что лагери в Бухенвальде—это были заводы, которые строили фау-айнс. Фау- айнс—это летающие бомбы немецкие.
David Boder: О! V-one?
Jacques Bramson: V-one.
David Boder: Да. [Неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: . . . бомбардировали. Да, да, да. Но надо сказать, что бомбардировка была произведена исключительно [неразборчиво]. Этот завод начинался в двадцати метрах от лагеря.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: И располагался...полтора километра длиной.
Jacques Bramson: Этот завод до единого камня был уничтожен; в лагерь попала всего лишь одна бомба [пауза], которая жертв тоже не сделала в самом лагере.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Jacques Bramson: Да, так что были жертвы только среди заключённых, которые в тот момент работали на заводе. Были убиты около двухсот пятидесяти эсэсов и около двухсот заключённых.
David Boder: Ну, да. [Неразборчиво, очень тихо]
Jacques Bramson: Между прочим, в связи с тем я могу рассказать интересную историю об этой бомбардировке.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: Место, где находится лагерь Бухенвальд—это гора над городом [пауза], над городом Ваймером.
Jacques Bramson: И вот эта гора над городом Ваймером была любимым местом Гёте.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво, очень тихо]
Jacques Bramson: И в центре лагеря Бухенвальда, [неразборчиво, сильные помехи] находился знаменитый дуб, который назывался дубом Гёте.
David Boder: Да, айхе.
Jacques Bramson: И вот все решительно деревья в лагере были уничтожены, но был...эээ...приказ этого дуба не трогать.
David Boder: Ага. Они были уничтожены немцами?
Jacques Bramson: Немцами.
David Boder: Ага, так.
Jacques Bramson: И вот...эээ...существует легенда. Это не только легенда, а это письмо...
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: . . . которое Гёте написал своему какому-то другу. И в этом письме Гёте говорит: «Когда у меня [неразборчиво], подымаюсь, подхожу к своему дубу и смотрю на него, и тогда надежда ко мне...
David Boder: . . . возвращается?
Jacques Bramson: . . . возвращается. Он такой могущественный, такой сильный, что олицетворяет для меня могущество нашего народа. [Пауза] И покаместь этот дуб будет стоять, немецкий народ будет тоже стоять». И сейчас все решительно с нетерпением ждали конца дуба [смеётся]. Так эта легенда усиленно рассказывалась в лагере. И эта единственная американская бомба, которая попала в лагерь Бухенвальд, попала именно в этот дуб. [Пауза] Этот дуб начал гореть. Так как он наполовину сгорел и так как он грозил тем, что упадёт на кухню, комендант лагеря по рупору велел передать, что ищет охотников, которые желают прийти, чтобы свалить дерево.
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: И к этому дереву бросился настоящий потоп.
Jacques Bramson: Запрещено в лагере топоры, пилы и всё, что Вы хотите. Я не знаю, откуда у всех заключённых появились пилы, топоры и несколько сот человек—две минуты после того, как это объявили—помчались на эту площадь [неразборчиво].
David Boder: И срубили дерево?
Jacques Bramson: И срубили этот дуб [смеётся].
David Boder: Так. Это интересно. И сколько вы ещё находились в Бухенвальде?
Jacques Bramson: [Неразборчиво] это, значит, был август месяц...Это август?
David Boder: Да, да, да.
Jacques Bramson: Тогда в апреле мы были освобождены, через семь месяцев.
David Boder: О! Через семь месяцев!
Jacques Bramson: Да.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво] Было грустно?
Jacques Bramson: Да, да.
David Boder: Не было разочарования?
Jacques Bramson: Да, было. Но Германия начала [неразборчиво] [говорит со смехом]
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: [Неразборчиво] было ещё одно приятное явление.
Jacques Bramson: В этом...когда мы выходили из лагеря, чтобы идти на работу, мы проходили так называемую Тарахавег.
David Boder: Тараха...вег?
Jacques Bramson: Да. Тарахавег—это была улица, которая [неразборчиво]. Когда-то в наши времена это было уничтожено. По этой улице нельзя было пройти, нужно было только бегать. Заключённые имели право только бегать.
David Boder: Почему?
Jacques Bramson: Вот, так они хотели. Там были [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Как Вы пишете это?
Jacques Bramson: Тарахо—как вы произносите.
David Boder: Ага. Хорошо. Тараховег.
Jacques Bramson: Да. Так вот в середине этой Тараховег стоял памятник, изображающий немецкий орёл, который держал свастику в руках. И всякий раз, когда мы проходили передэтим орлом, надо было снимать шляпу и не надо было держать руки в карманах.
David Boder: Какие шляпы у вас были?
Jacques Bramson: У нас самые невероятные. У нас даже женские шляпы были: то, что нам давали, то мы и одевали [говорит со смехом].
David Boder: Так.
Jacques Bramson: [Неразборчиво] Каждый раз, когда мы возвращались и не снимали шапки [неразборчиво] избивали, иногда даже застреливали. И вот после бомбардировки птичка свалилась, и от орла ничего не осталось! [Смеётся]